this is a production of Cornell
University thanks Carrie for that very
generous introduction and thanks
everyone for being here today I'm
excited to talk to you about my
dissertation research on peace and
criminais harem there we go hi so I'll
start with the refresher on Caesarea
McCrimmon air and biology for everyone
this is a fungal pathogen of wheat corn
and other grasses it reduces crop yields
and contaminates grain mycotoxin and
economically it causes direct losses of
about a billion dollars each year in the
United States and also produces very
striking red pigments and culture I can
be identified on host plants by this
characteristic pink salmon spore ulation
and infected grain is visibly pale and
shriveled compared to healthy grain as
you can see here it's a very simplified
lifecycle I need you to remember it for
the rest of my talk the pathogen
overwinters in dead plant tissue and in
the spring it produces airborne
ascospores the Sarah Baker manera MS
homo phthalic so a single individual is
able to produce the sexual spores and
they can potentially travel several
kilometers before landing on and
infecting host plants while they're
flowering and particularly vulnerable to
the pathogen roots and stems are also
susceptible to infection through the
soil or debris at the soil surface and
this could lead to additional stem
colonization and pathogen overwintering
picture on the left is of parity SIA
which contain ask spores on a corn stalk
and corn stubble is generally considered
the primary source of disease-causing
inoculum in agricultural settings the
other picture here is of a wheat grass
panicle with a single infected spikelet
the bleaching symptom is typical and if
you look at the right side of the spike
you can see the anthers poking out
indicating that infection occurred early
during the flowering process this
pathogen is extremely well studied
we have successful breeding programs we
use effective fungicides on over 70% of
planted acres we have weather based
models to predict risk in real time and
we have these promising biological
control agents being developed we still
see ten percent losses on the whole and
at the individual field level
severe disease epidemics can result in a
complete loss so a big picture question
might be what else could we be studying
about this pathogen and you can probably
guess my answer based on the
title of the presentation it's wild
hosts wild hosts are interesting for a
number of reasons first of all most of
what we know about Fusarium Grubin air
and was discovered in an agricultural
context really focusing on wheat and
corn but Fusarium criminais Arum doesn't
exist solely in cropping systems and in
fact cultivated crops are only a
fraction of the pathogens host range it
can infect well over a hundred species
spread across more than two dozen plant
families and I want this slide to give
you a sense of that scale each circle
here represents a plant family and their
relative size indicates how many hosts
are contained within each all these
hosts could potentially influence
disease epidemiology or pathogen
evolution but the research I'm sharing
today focuses on hosts the PO AC which
is the true grass family
it contains the largest group of host
species as well as the most important
agricultural crops other reasons to
focus on grasses include their
widespread distribution and remarkably
high acreage these are satellite images
showing wheat and brass ground cover in
New York and Kansas I've chosen Kansas
as an example because the largest wheat
producing state in the country but six
to seven million acres planted a year
but grass covers three times that land
area and I like this image especially
because it shows that interface between
the wheat and the grasses in New York
though the disparity is much greater in
almost twenty to one and earlier I
mentioned corn being an important part
of the disease cycle and for reference
New York still has twice as much grass
as corn making this an especially good
place to study she's areum in these
isolated grass communities and in
addition to the sheer numbers of these
hosts they're often growing in close
proximity to crops for example fallow
fields pastures or even in the margins
of wheat fields themselves that presents
a lot of opportunities for the pathogen
to move back and forth between hosts so
despite their widespread distribution
very little is known about the
interaction Gruber nerim with wild
grasses and the goal of my dissertation
research has been to characterize the
pathogens biology and wild grass hosts
at a population and community level and
then to relate this new information back
to our understanding of disease in wheat
fields we've been looking at this
Fusarium grass relationship from a few
different perspectives and I've divided
my talk into five sections based on the
topics listed
slide and it starts with a study on the
incidence of Fusarium grooming err I'm
in wild grasses and I put this photo
here because the grasses I'm talking
about our own oysters almost always
infected a symptomatically
and this was the only time but I saw
Fusarium growing on the outside of the
grass spike if you look closely you
could see the spore nokia they're bright
orange and they contain be asexual
comitia so a little more backgrounds
like I just mentioned these asymptomatic
associations are well documented in
surveys from around the world but no
other study has considered the
environmental factors that might
influence pathogen distribution we
wanted answer these two questions is
incidence homogeneous across the state
and what factors might contribute to
grass colonization to do that we
conducted a field survey of grass spikes
and overwintered grass stems from very
different locations we collected samples
from 23 sites over three years we
focused on twelve common grass species
and we also collected infected wheat
spikes for crop fields the sites were
divided between two regions of New York
the central region which contains most
of the state's grain production and the
Northeast which has virtually no wheat
or other small grains and much less corn
so there were samples from regions with
high and low agricultural production we
also sampled locations under two
different land uses one being
agricultural so these are wheat fields
where I collected grasses from around
the margins they were land-use was
natural and this included remote regions
in the Adirondacks Montezuma National
Wildlife Refuge just north of Cayuga
Lake and other non agricultural
environments that had undisturbed
grasses growing soin totally collected
more than three thousand grass spikes
and three thousand stems we isolated
Fusarium from this tissue kept count of
the incidents of criminais Arum but also
held onto all of the other Fusarium
species and that comes into play a
little bit later so we compared Fusarium
grew manure and recovery rates between
region and land use plots here have
region on the x-axis percent pathogen
incidence on the y-axis with stems and
the pile on the left and spikes on the
plot on the right land uses color-coded
in both cases there was less Fusarium in
the northeastern part of the state a
difference was very clear looking at the
infestation rates of overwintered stems
but the variation and spike incidence
was much larger and while on average
there
you were infections in the Northeast the
difference is less obvious and that's
because a lot of the variation is tied
up in the weather that we experience
during each of our sampling years so
here's the same data split by year
instead of region and land use 2015 was
an epidemic year for sorry I'm head
blight and at one sampling site all of
the grass spikes collected contain the
pathogen and that high level of
infection provides a lot of
opportunities for the pathogen to call a
nice stem tissue and an overwinter which
is why we see high number of stems
infested the following year in 2016
there's a severe drought in 2016 which
meant few spike infections that season
and turn that results in less
overwintering and stems following year
in 2017 we wanted to move beyond those
categorical differences so we modeled
pathogen incidents and spikes based on
two continuous variables rainfall and
host density I put these graphic
representations here for you to see how
much variation there is across the state
cumulative rainfall in May and June was
chosen as a proxy for a relative
humidity which is known to impact spore
production release and crop infection
and our rainfall estimates for taking it
from the prison climate group at Oregon
State the plot on the right shows host
density in the air prior to sampling
which is an indirect estimate of
pathogen inoculum production and the
year samples were collected and the
image here shows the total acreage of
Grass corn and small grains including
wheat at one kilometer intervals and
this makes for a simple visual but in
reality we use a slightly more
complicated variable and then our model
host acreage was summed within 10
kilometers of every sampling site and
acres were weighted based on their
distance from the sampling site so host
ten kilometers away were considered much
less important than hosts within one
kilometer where we collected a sample
and we settled on this ten kilometer
combined acreage after testing the hosts
together and separately across a range
of distances from one to ten kilometers
so the output from our model of grass
spike incidents suggests that both
density and rainfall or required for
grass infection which makes good
biological sense and this corresponds to
higher inoculant production as well as
the environmental conditions be
conducive to disease opossum is slide
showed 95 percent confidence intervals
around predicted pathogen incidence
rates x-axis is your cumulative rainfall
estimate
y-axis is the percent of predicted
spiked infections and as you move across
the slide from the left to the right
each pot has a different as an
increasing number of host acres so the
left most spots resemble what we saw in
northeastern New York and their thoughts
on the right are more similar to what we
would have seen in central New York and
so you get this rapid rise in pathogen
incidents with increasing rainfall once
there's a certain level of background
host density another trend we noticed in
the data was a tendency for cherem
criminais Arum to displace other
Fusarium species at field sites with
more rainfall and higher host densities
and this is a plot using the same model
as before but now including the ratio of
Fusarium groomin air i'm Fusarium
species rather than just criminais RM
incidence and at low host densities it's
roughly a 50/50 split between grooming a
harem and other species but when
conditions favored for the spread of
gramineae Arum we see that ratio change
very drastically this is probably
because criminais arm produces those
aerial arioli dispersed ascospores
and none of the other grass associated
Fusarium species are known to do this so
higher rainfall would especially benefit
in criminais over other abuse area to
wrap up that section grass debris is a
likely source of anxiety of disease and
sighting inoculum and could increase the
risk of epidemics and nearby crops
incidents in grass spikes varies with
annual weather patterns and hosts
density in a manner consistent with what
we know about we what we know about crop
hosts and there was an unexpected
finding where we saw this change in
caesarea and species communities
associated with those same factors the
next part of the talk focuses on how
exactly those communities differed and
why this could impact agricultural crops
again a little more background as I've
mentioned multiple feasts area can
inhabit grass spikes many of them are
also crop pathogens and most of them
produce some cocktail of toxins so we
wanted to find out what other Fusarium
species were showing up in our grass
samples in addition to that I wanted to
figure out how the Fusarium communities
might be structured so we sequenced gene
fragments from about 400 unknown
isolates and we identified ten different
Fusarium species in addition to criminal
some of them were well known crop
pathogens several wore common sapper
fights
but there were two unusual finds that I
think are fun to point out this is the
second time Fusarium campus heiress has
been found in the US and typically it's
seen on rotting tropical fruits like
banana and cacao and this is the only
time Fusarium lactis has been associated
with the grass host it's mostly known
for affecting sweet peppers but it also
causes an internal route of figs when
it's introduced to the fruit by big
wasps like this one pictured here
so there were certainly some interesting
species to be found and when we compare
species diversity across sites we can
see the diversity was slightly lower in
central New York than in northeastern
New York and the plot here just shows
Simpsons diversity index where a lower
number means less species diversity
another way to compare species diversity
between locations is to look at
differences between the communities
taken from different field sites and
when we do that we see a significant
shift between the communities from our
two regions each point on this plot
represents a field site and the distance
between points shows the relative
difference between their Fusarium
communities the color scheme has changed
now orange represents northeastern New
York blue Central New York darker colors
stand for the agricultural sites and
lighter for the natural sites and you
can see that while the regions are
slightly separated the two land uses are
not differentiated at all we wanted to
see what was actually different between
these communities so we ran a principal
components analysis on our species
abundance data and it turned out that
98% of community variation could be
explained by just two species criminais
arimin sports are coyotes and this is
not too surprising because if you just
look at the raw frequency of all 11
species isolated shown here in the pie
chart these two are clearly the dominant
members what's more interesting though
is that the two distinct species Aaron
is that two distinct Fusarium
communities were associated with each at
least dominant species
Grima nerim was generally found
alongside less common species and Sapir
fights while sports are Cody's was
associated with other well-known crop
allergens this heat map here shows the
strength of co-occurrences between
species and I've added boxes around the
two clusters to make the divide between
those communities more clear and this is
important because the very species in
each of these groups can produce a
different variety of toxins
if you were trying to predict what
contaminants might appear in harvested
grain understanding the environmental
factors shaping these communities could
be a useful predictive tool and then
just to recap that survey and wild
grasses revealed some interesting
Fusarium species diversity and
understanding how communities form under
those different conditions could be
valuable for predicting disease risk
after looking at species and community
diversity we took a look at the genetic
diversity within Fusarium crimini rim
populations and to put this into context
we need to start from a very broad point
of view saerom guru nerim is really a
species complex with over a dozen member
species member species are more or less
restricted by geography and this neat
little map just shows their suspected
geographic origins but the most
important member retains the name
Fusarium grameen Ihram and it's globally
distributed it's also by far the most
important species in north america
looking at just the united states
Fusarium criminais um and that narrow
sense is the predominant species there
are three populations that exist in
overlapping geographic ranges shown here
on this map of the US and these
populations are roughly defined by their
production of different mycotoxins
variants also known as schema types and
his chemo types could be predicted from
single gene markers i don't want to get
bogged down on their chemical structures
i've just listed the three most
important chemo types and their
associated north american populations
here while the populations do overlap
isolates of each our president different
ratios that change across north-south
and east-west gradients the North
American one population is predominant
in the south and west but as you move
north or east you find more of the North
American two population this na3
population was only discovered recently
and it's known geographic range is much
more restricted but prevailing
hypothesis is that this chemo type
evolved after the others and originated
in the extreme north eastern United
States or in Canada and I point all of
us out because New York sits
conveniently at the intersection of
these gradients because of this New York
has a very unique mixture of these three
populations we also happen to have the
highest known frequency of this n X
these n x2 producing isolates that
corresponds to that na3 populate
based on previous work in gary's lab
looking at isolettes collected from
wheat corn and airborne spores
we know that the 381 and nx2 producing
isolates occur at a higher frequency
only in the northeastern part of the
state these pie charts represent that so
the most important parts of background
information for this part of the talk
there are three distinct populations
that are mostly differentiated by their
chemo type New York is a particularly
interesting place to study these
populations isolates derived from wild
grasses have not been considered in
previous population genetic studies and
as a reminder we collected wheat
isolates during our field survey so
based on that there are a lot of
questions worth asking but these are the
four that I'm going to tell you about do
land use or wild hosts influence chemo
type ratios how well do neutral genetic
markers compare to our single locus
chemo type markers when compared in
populations what amount of gene flow is
expected and by extension how much
pathogen movement could occur between
hosts and who different hosts or sites
serve as reservoirs of genetic diversity
to start with we estimated tumor type
frequency using 900 isolates and then we
compared their occurrence based on
different factors we did not see a
difference between the 3 host sources
wheat spikes grass spikes or grass stems
and there was a significant change in
chemo type frequency between central and
northeastern New York as expected but
there is also a significant difference
between land use at sites in central New
York where the prevalence of the 381
chemo type was expanded in natural
settings compared to what we found in
agricultural fields and we would
consider that to be a novel and pretty
interesting finding because it suggests
that even at relatively small geographic
scales some unknown factor is able to
maintain different ratios of these
populations across sites building on
that analysis we used 8 microsatellite
markers to genotype these same isolates
and these neutral markers do correspond
pretty closely to the chemo type
assignments the scatterplot is from a
discriminant analysis of principal
components which i've used here to show
how well prior group assignments
compared to observed genetic structure
each point represents an individual
isolate there
color-coded here by population and the
discriminant analysis is attempting to
separate the populations as much as
possible and in this case the plot shows
that while the genetic distance between
our groups small they can be clearly
differentiated based on the chemo type
labels the inset at the bottom-left of
the plot is just there to indicate that
we've captured about 90% of the
variation in our data set and the
density plot on the top right of the
slide shows the values for just one of
the axes in the scatter plot and I want
that there to drive home the overlap
between these predefined populations
you can also numerically quantify
population differentiation between
groups and there are a hundred and one
ways to do this I just want to share one
common measurement with you the table at
the bottom right of the slide shows a
pairwise fixation index in this case
hedrick's GST which ranges from 0 to 1
with 1 being complete differentiation
and 0 being no differentiation
whatsoever looking at the pairwise
values here the NX to Kemah type is less
differentiated than the 3 and 15
supporting the pattern of population
overlap shown by the discriminant
analysis and generally speaking those
numbers would be considered to indicate
moderate differentiation running the
analysis a second time but setting
population groups based on region and
land use we see much less
differentiation there though there are
some bumps in the data showing that
subsets of these groups are more
distantly related than others you can
see for example this more dispersed
group of isolates from the natural sites
in central New York marked and light
blue and I think the density plot also
shows us pretty well where you could see
these second peaks for the natural sites
in both central New York and
northeastern New York look at the
fixation indexes for these groupings
there is a slight differentiation
between all groups but much less than we
saw between kimo types finally here's
one more look at this data where groups
were defined based on host source right
meet grass by expressed stems and
because there's virtually no
differentiation here you might infer
that unrestricted gene flow and by
extension possibly pathogen movement
could occur between all three of his
hosts
a last thing I want to mention about
this relates to genetic diversity and
how it was evenly spread between isolate
sources so the 700 isolates that we
fully genotyped only about 50 were
identified as clones which means
genotypic diversity was extremely high
as in 0.99 on a scale of 0 to 1 we also
saw equivalent allele diversity listed
here as mean allele numbers and gene
diversity and even the number of unique
alleles from each source was more or
less equivalent so to recap that while
grasses are a reservoir of neutral gene
diversity in one sense they don't
contain off a higher level of diversity
than wheat does pathogen movement
between these hosts does not appear
limited by any kind of population
structure non agricultural environments
support a different ratio of pathogen
kimo types than wheat fields and because
we suspect genetic recombination is
occurring between 3 populations with
different stalks and production profiles
we should be on the lookout for an
animal toxin production or altered
variants these populations particularly
at sites where we might find high
admixture rates so we saw a very little
genetic differentiation between isolates
taken from grasses and wheat suggesting
no major constraints to colonization of
different host spikes and to follow up
on this we examine some of the other
interactions between the pathogen and
individual grass hosts a little more
background host-pathogen interactions
and this Fusarium grass system have not
been characterized very well and if you
Serangoon a-arm can also cause root and
Crown rots
the central question we wanted to get
out here was how competent are various
grass host we measure the hosts
competency of five grasses during three
stages in the pathogen lifecycle and to
be clear and define host competency is
the ability to support pathogen survival
reproduction and infection so we examine
each of these in separate experiments
the first was a winter survival assay
that went on for two years and measured
pathogen persistence and individual stem
pieces that were artificially inoculated
and left outside this bar chart shows
pathogen recovery from the stems of
various wild grasses and wheat Triticum
aestivum which for the next couple of
slides is always going to be shown on
the far right of the x-axis
black bars here pathogens survival rates
after a single year and the gray bar
shows survival after two years four of
the five grasses tested were comparable
to wheat one host was significantly
worse as an overwintering site and all
the others and it was clearly related to
how quickly the stems had degraded there
was also a steep decline in pathogens
survival between the first and second
year which agrees with past research
that focused on wheat stems on loan the
second experiment was a spore production
assay conducted under controlled
conditions these are 95% confidence
interval plots of spore production on
different host stems the y-axis is log
transformed and spore production was
adjusted to dry grams of host tissue
before comparison we also averaged the
spore production of ten diverse isolates
on each host so one grass was less
suitable as a substrate for spore
production than the others but all of
them supported the production of huge
numbers of both ask us for shot on the
plot on the left and Canadia the plot on
the right and again you can see we
discommode the most of these grasses and
finally the third experiment was a
seedling root rot assay where we
recorded the number of seedlings
infected after inoculating seeds at
germination we used to five different
eye slits for this and they were chosen
because they have these different chemo
types and I split them apart here
because there is a significant
interaction between host and isolate
meaning that some of the isolates tested
were more or less virulent on different
grasses and there were two grasses that
seemed pretty resistant to infection
three others that were all susceptible
but showed lower incidence rates the
weep this indicates that at least some
level of host specialization could exist
at different eye slits and clearly the
pathogen is better adapted to infecting
weeds and grass seedlings to wrap that
up all the hosts for suitable substrates
for production most of them were
comparable to eat as overwintering sites
and to different grasses were not
susceptible to seedling root rot and
together those results suggest that
various grass hosts could have different
selective pressures than pathogen to
build on that last point we wanted to
compare the fitness of some eye slits
derived from wheat and grafts to see if
there was any separation in phenotypes
that might be related to their host of
origin
there's no more background here because
you're all experts on this by now and
the question is straightforward enough
does Fitness differ between host sources
we took a dozen eye slits from wheat and
a dozen eye slits from grass bikes all
collected at the same field site and we
phenotype them in nine different
experiments where we measured growth
reproduction on different substrates and
variants on two crops this radar chart
displays the mean relative fitness of
eye slits from both sources and each
spoke on the wheel just marks a
different experiment so right away you
might be able to see where some of the
differences could be we derived iceless
displayed by the gray area we're better
at producing Canadia or asexual spores
and had a slight advantage when
infecting wheat or corn grass derived
eye slits shown in blue were better at
reproducing asexually generating more
parasya on three of the four substrates
we tested and I also had marginally
faster growth rates based on those rough
comparisons we formerly tested for
differences and mean phenotype values of
interest and we found that wheat derived
isolates produced larger Canadia and
more Canadia than grass derived eye
slits as shown here and these two plots
now finding just highlights the
importance of looking at phenotype
distributions in addition to genotypes
with studying populations and it also
suggests that wheat and grasses could be
selecting for different traits relevant
to agriculture this is worth
investigating further because grasses
could actually serve as a buffer against
the evolution of traits too detrimental
to agriculture for example providing
refuge from fungicide applications and
helping to maintain low levels of
resistance and I think I can sum most of
what I've talked about today so these
two points one wild grasses are suitable
hosts and likely sources of inoculum
based on surveys experiments and
inferences from population genetics and
to the factors that were strongly
influencing pathogen incidence
communities and population structure
generally operated on ten kilometer or
greater scales I think both of those
ideas are relevant to land use choices
like where to plant crops and could be
incorporated to disease risk assessments
Gary alluded to the fact that I have
quite a few hobby projects and I'm not
gonna get into all of them today I just
want to give a shout out to some of the
great collaborators I've been able to
work with that Cornell Matt Ryan's lab
is doing some very exciting work on
cropping systems that incorporate
perennial grains including an
intermediate wheatgrass called Kern's
the picture here on the left and I've
been able to team up with Eugene Law to
hunt for pathogens in their field trials
and it's been a real treat to look for
disease in these new hosts I've also
worked a lot with mark Sorel's plant
breeding program scout in the fields his
group plants all over the state and it's
provided a lot of data on disease
incidence patterns as well as great
information on crop variety performance
and some of these field sites are also
in pretty interesting places and I took
this photo of Jay and Alisa at the
Wegmans organic research farm and with
that I want to thank Gary for having me
in his program it's been an incredible
experience and I think it's fair to say
that he has given me the freedom to
pursue my interests wherever they lead
and a few of you might even remember my
first student seminar when I talked
about trying to identify picture plan
diseases which is pretty far removed
from field crops and really a testament
to how much freedom I was given to
explore here I also need to mention some
of the undergraduates I've worked with
and the students on this slide were all
involved in my dissertation research
Kelly and Julianne who I unfortunately
don't have pictures of helped me conduct
some of the laboratory experiments
eniola was characterized in Fusarium
communities last summer she had never
worked in a lab before but did a really
fantastic job but now she's looking out
for her next research experience Manchus
kwon extracted more DNA than anyone
should ever be asked to and now he's in
a ph.d program at Purdue and Jay Winans
was an all-around superstar he did an
undergraduate thesis with us he worked
on every part of his research and he
also helped with fur for other projects
right now he's working with Nancy Keller
at wisconsin-madison obviously there are
a lot of other people have helped me and
I hope I haven't forgotten any of them
thanks for listening and I know I have
plenty of time left for questions
[Applause]
I've questioned that I wouldn't see if
my interpretation makes sense based on
this area so I found that result of the
difference between asexual versus sexual
spore production and The Weavers graphs
really interesting and it seems like it
would be consistent with say the
hypothesis that they're better at
producing sexual spores there's more
genetic recombination that maybe that
makes them more suited to a were
clinically diverse host population
versus a less more attractive form those
population where there might be an
advantage and producing more asexual
spores that take life right does that
make sense based on the biology yeah so
the question is about the preference for
asexual versus sexual reproduction
depending on host diversity and I think
that hypothesis could make sense
unfortunately the data we had didn't
show a significant difference between
the two and the overlap in phenotypic
distributions for iceless that you
collect is pretty wide so it would be
hard to get a sample size large enough I
think to answer that definitively but
it's definitely an interesting idea
yeah like almost completely so how much
recombination yeah so the question is
about how sexual Sharon groom harem is
and we see it out cross if there's
another isolate available for it to
reproduce with your data I probably
could but I have not yet and that is
something I could analyze using the
micro satellite markers potentially
thanks very interesting seminar Mike so
what are the implications for time
readers
is there is there likelihood that you
know we don't have very good resistance
in weed but with all that diversity do
you think that that this pathogen can
overcome what little resistance we even
have yes that's a great question about
how much diversity is in Fusarium grim
nerim and what that means for breeding
programs I think one interesting thing
to do would be to use a much wider range
of isolates when a Seine for resistance
and yes it certainly would pose a
challenge for any resistance you find
having this wide range of phenotypes in
the field but I think another
potentially interesting thing to look at
is a gene for gene interactions maybe
that are happening in wild grasses and
cerium at the system and whether any of
those might give insight or hints into
what kind of resistance could be useful
in and we addition to what we're already
trying to breed for sure bill you see
any widespread distribution of
particular genotypes to Germany so
question being about distribution of
single clonal genotypes yeah so we
genotype 750 cultures we found 50 clones
occasionally they were in the same place
generally they were in different places
we know long-range dispersal is a
potential thing that could happen but
with such a small number of clones it's
hard to say what that distance might
actually look like mega toxin because
what we're more interested in a breeding
is not written so said along the wild
species or a systematic just curious if
maybe you had make peasants that are
stopping mycotoxin yeah so questions
about mycotoxin accumulation and wild
grasses and
oh we didn't look at that specifically
there is another group that has done
that and under natural conditions the
grasses accumulated very little to no
mica toxin whatsoever
if you inoculate them in a greenhouse
though then they blow up and sometimes
you can see symptoms and then you have
accumulation of don another mica toxins
as well so yeah there's definitely
something interesting there I think
would be really cool to look at more
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu